♪♪
>>> ALL RIGHT, SO WE GOT SO
MACHINES RIGHT HERE, WE GOT
BIG PRIZES, SMALL PRIZES.
YOU GUYS, WE JUST NEED YOU
INITIAL AND SIGN THIS.
>> OH.
SURE.
>> AND YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> AND CONGRATULATIONS, YOUS
ARE OFFICIALLY MEMBERS OF T
POGIE FAMILY.
>> OKAY.
SO I JUST GOT HIRED AT POGI
PEPPERONI'S, THE PLACE THAT
PRACTICALLY SHAPED MY CHILD.
GAMES, THE PIZZA AND TOWN,
SOME OF THE COOLEST PEOPLE
EVER MET.
>> YEAH.
SOUNDS LIKE A NORMAL JOB TO.
>> I HAVE A COUPLE MORE THI
FOR YOU.
HERE'S YOUR UNIFORM.
>> OKAY.
MY VERY OWN POGIE SHIRT, 'C
THAT'S NORMAL.
I'M SORRY, JUST TO CLARIFY,
THAT'S POGIE PEPPERONI ON A
SKATEBOARD ABOUT TO GO ON OF
HIS FAMOUS ADVENTURES.
>> YEAH, I MEAN I GUESS SO.
>> AND I IMAGINE WE HAVE TO
LEAVE THESE HERE AT WORK?
NOPE.
YOU CAN TAKE THEM HOME JUSTH
THEM, MAKE SURE THEY'RE CLE.
>> SO WE CAN ACTUALLY WEAR E
OUT AND MEET NEW PEOPLE CAU
THAT'S NOT A HUGE GAME CHAN
IN MY LIFE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M SORRY AND HOW MUCH W
THESE BE COSTING US?
>> THEY FREE, MAN.
>> THAT'S NORMAL.
YEAH.
>> OKAY, I'M GOOD.
>> SURE.
>> ACTUALLY, I FORGOT SOMET,
I'LL BE BACK IN A SEC.
>> DON'T SAY ANYTHING.
>> WHY WOULD I SAY ANYTHING?
>> Both: DUDE, THIS IS AWES!
>> WE WORK AT POGIES!
[ CHEERS ]
>> WHAT'S THAT?
>> OH, NOTHING, MISS CHARLE.
EVERYTHING'S IN ORDER, MISS
CHARLENE.
♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE'S 20 TOK
EACH, Y'ALL SUPPOSED TO PLAE
GAMES SO YOU'LL KNOW ABOUT .
>> EXCUSE ME, WHAT WAS THATT
PART?
>> EMPLOYEES GET TOKENS TO
THE GAMES.
>> WE PROBABLY JUST HAVE AC
TO WHAT, ONE, TWO GAMES TOP?
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER, DUDE.
PLAY WHATEVER YOU WANT.
>> OKAY.
>> OKAY, WELL --
>> FROGGY FRENZY, ROCKO'S
REVENGE, ANY OF THEM?
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE NORMAL WOR
ACTIVITIES TO ME.
>> YEAH, THAT DEFINITELY HAS
AT ALL THE PLACES WE WORK A.
>> STALL ON TABLE FIVE.
>> I GOTTA GO DEAL WITH THA.
OKAY?
>> OH, NO PROBLEM.
>> YEAH.
DON'T SAY ANYTHING.
>> I'M NOT SAYING A SINGLE
THING.
♪♪
>> Both: DUDE, THIS IS AWES!
>> WE'RE RICH!
>> LOOK AT ALL THESE TOKENS!
[ SCREAMS ]
♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> AND THIS DAY OFFICIALLY T
GET ANY BETTER.
♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> PLEASE TELL ME THAT'S NOO
I THINK IT IS.
>> AND POGIE IS WALKING UP
TALK TO US RIGHT NOW.
♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HEY, YOU MUST BE THE NEW
POGIE RECRUITS, I'M NATHAN.
>> WE ARE REG AND A.C. SANT.
>> COOL, I'LL TRY TO REMEMB
THAT.
ANYWAY I GOT FIVE MINUTES BE
THIS DUMBASS 3:00 P.M. POGI
PARADE.
I'LL SEE YOU FOOLS LATER.
>> Both: SEE YOU, POGIE.
>> BECAUSE I GUESS WE'RE FRS
NOW.
>> DON'T FREAK OUT.
>> I'M NOT FREAKING OUT.
>> Both: DUDE, THIS IS AWES!
♪♪
>> WE JUST MET POGIE PEPPER!
AND HE'S PLAYED BY NATHAN W
SEEMS LIKE A REALLY COOL GU!
[ SCREAMS ]
>> ARE YOU GUYS COOL?
>> COOL, YEAH, WE'RE COOL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU DON'T SEEM LIKE IT.
♪♪
>> AND ONE MORE SLICE.
>> PUT HER DOWN.
>> PERFECT.
>> REG, A.C. SANTANO.
>> YES, MISS CHARLENE?
>> THIS IS ASHLIN, THE OWNE
POGIE'S PEPPERONI.
♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]